foreign
[Music]
took better care of me than humans sort
of
and our people Maya
it's just programming
ten years ago today the artificial
intelligence created to protect us
detonated a nuclear warhead in Los
Angeles
this is a fight for our very existence
we are this close to winning the war
of the AI are developing a super weapon
retrieve it
but they went
[Music]
did you locate the weapon yeah she's the
kid no
no you gotta be a good person to go to
heaven so we're the same we can't go to
heaven because you're not good
and I'm not a person
she looks like a little girl now but
she's growing
Whoever has that kid wins the war
[Applause]
what do you want sweetie for robots to
be free
oh we don't have that in the fridge how
about ice cream
welcome home honey
do you read now what is this it's
classified
come with you oh I'm sorry
you weren't invited
the dangerous
hey why are you here I got this
situation when I need your help pretty
bad friends
cause I'm the new guy is that sniper
don't worry about it I got a
prescription oh guys remember this face
oh shoot it by accident
terrorists have taken possession of
nuclear missiles on a cargo ship off the
coast
if these babies go off
it'll be World War III
over family
time to get loud
let's fly baby
soon
come on
that's what I'm talking about
[Music]
is that the biggest one you've got oh
it's way bigger than that
thank you
this world is beyond cruelty
you've been fighting the arguments for
decades
my family's been fighting them for
centuries
they were massacred
alongside my father my father didn't
believe in Revenge
we believe in from it let me fight
beside you
thank you
[Music]
I won't be fighting for him
I'm fighting for my people
[Music]
can you believe in Paul
there are signs
Prophet why is that a bad thing use it
because all my Visions lead to horror
because you lose control because I gain
it
Johnny do you believe in me
Paula trades are still alive
deal with this prophet
[Music]
show me who you are
weak man
hi
look who's back from the dead
now do it must be done
we gave them something to hope for
I will love you as long as I breathe
this prophecy is how they enslave us
it's not a prophecy it's a story I don't
care what you believe I believe
joke Uncle Ruckus
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
we must make an example our France will
fall
what would you do with this assignment
of defense was transferred to you
[Applause]
I promise you brilliant successes
[Music]
this is my uniform
too long
what is your name Napoleon
the course of my life has changed
Napoleon
I'm destined for greatness
for those sword
I suggest you take the throne as a king
so we vote
[Applause]
this learning has held the world of
Hostage with his egotism and his lack of
simple good manners
I think you're great
there is nothing without me
of your business forces against me
what's the outcome of this if you don't
succeed
Your Majesty we are discovered good
first two admit when I make a mistake
I simply never do
[Music]
[Applause]
my son never show Mercy
great
we
are predators
boys your mother is dead
she died because you sent her away she
was weak sick in her mind you know my
business yes
power is about strength if you show
weakness you will give our enemies an
opening
[Applause]
come on
this week like his mother leave him
what happened that day
I stared death in the face and for the
first time I saw my true self
tell me about this Hunter
they say he uses a connection with
animals to track his prey
once you're on his list
there's only one way off the six of us
only one of you there's six of you now
[Music]
why do you hunt my father puts evil into
the world
I take it out
[Music]
thank you thank you
you were exactly like our father just
another man hunting foreign
[Music]
Mr tagline
Mr tackling
where's Mr tagley oh you're standing in
him
you're goddamn lunatic oh you just
figure that out now
there is an animal in each one of us
don't you want to know why they call me
the rhino
thank you
what the
[Applause]
ing
[Music]
[Applause]
Sonia Cuisine returning my view
foreign
[Music]
that's what I'll give you to decide your
faith
[Music]
Roberto tell me what did you do back
home
government work I'm retired for you
because of these people I'm beginning to
understand real people and I'm starting
to believe
this is where I'm supposed to be
foreign
[Music]
you don't want it to go to a level four
oh
I seem like a man who understands
violence
you can't take that from me
I can take anything I want
police found multiple dead bodies on
that farm in Sicily if you kill him
[Music]
nine seconds
um
do I look like a killer
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Jonas we need your help
we're detecting increased aquatic
activity 25 000 feet deep in the trench
it's an ancient ecosystem Untouched by
men whatever is down there is trying to
make its way to the surface
this is a bad idea
just a little bit
[Music]
Jonas
we've got company
the biggest snake I've ever seen
biggest bag anyone's ever seen
the apex predator
everybody might get to the station
every massive exit who knows what else
to escape the breach
I just hope it goes better than last
time
what happened last time
I don't know
[Applause]
we've never seen this before they hunted
it back
foreign
was always afraid of this but I was also
thinking
[Music]
the best driver is probably Rory I would
dust him in a laugh
all you do is play video games with some
crazy dreams of racing cars Doug you're
the one that told us to always do
something we love
and cars cost
look around it's not our world son
what is this it's a contest
the best Gran Turismo players in the
world
get a chance to compete in professional
racing dude this is real
[Applause]
is really
I'm sorry you really think you're gonna
take a kid who plays video games in
their bedroom you're gonna strap them to
a 200 mile an hour rocket it'll tear
them to pieces
it's not gonna work the guys who race
are Elite athletes but I won't stop now
your kids are scrawny little gamer kids
I swear you coming come on let's go
must be a new experience for you moving
your legs
you puked on my lawn there's no turning
back man when you're in a race the
cockpit is going to be 140 degrees
Fahrenheit
the g-forces will be twice what an
astronaut experiences upon liftoff I
can't see anything
hey you get extra points for that in the
game
[Music]
this whole thing is insane without the
Couchsurfing nerds that you sent me he
is the best one he made it yeah welcome
to Team Nissan
[Music]
you miss it on the track
you could die
I know this track
man I've raced it a thousand times
talking about
but I won't stop now
are you gonna answer that
it's not mine
[Music]
sorry who is this
foreign
honey Something's Happened there's a man
who's put a bomb in the car under our
seats there are pressure triggers
we can't get up the car will explode
we're here listen very carefully or I
kill you open the glove box
why are you doing this what have I ever
done to you this life or yours Matt I'm
your best friend
[Music]
I think I'm the bomber
well I guess you've had a tough day
I know that you've lost a lot of money
for your clients who invested in your
fund
a lot of people are worried about you
've got everybody's attention man
come out there
if I will
no you're not you hurt my darling son of
a I will kill you
What's it gonna be
Drive
killed Danvers prodigal child of the
Milky Way
Nick Fury my favorite one-eyed man of
intrigue how goes it out there I don't
know cold No Air
space
[Applause]
Captain Marvel the annihilator
you took everything from me
and now I'm returning the favor
what is happening to me
[Music]
she's entangled our light-based powers
so we switch places whenever we use them
you can absorb light
I can see it and Kamala who's Kamala hi
she can turn light into physical matter
which I have never heard of I could
totally show you no
to listen
to delicious
[Music]
profile
he's targeting every planet we call home
I would never choose to bring anybody
into this
you are not the only thing standing
between this and the universe
[Music]
faster
I can't can you I got it
this is Bella
Bella this is Mr McCandless
hello Bella
no
she's an experiment good evening and
rainy and her body are not quite
synchronized
but she is progressing at an accelerated
piece
[Music]
tell me where did she come from
or it is a happy tail
[Music]
I am Bella Baxter and there is a world
to enjoy so I can navigate it is the
goal of all to progress grow a woman
plotting her cause of freedom and do not
vote
[Music]
good
Ness
[Music]
oh
I am honored to introduce to you the
creator of The Hunger Games themselves
Dean casca High bottom
I have summoned you all here for the
10th Annual reaping ceremony in which we
choose two children from each district
to fight to the death in The Hunger
Games from District 12 Lucy gray bear
[Music]
there has been a change this year as a
mentor Mr snow Your Role is to turn
these children into spectacles not
survivors
what does my mentor do besides bring me
roses I do my best to take care of you
you really want to take care of me in
that Arena
you start by thinking I can actually win
I'm lucky flickerman first ever host of
The Hunger Games
[Music]
enjoy the show
what happens in there
filled with the terror becoming prey
there quickly we become predator
see how quickly civilization disappears
foreign
[Music]
across that line into evil
or not
you hear that boy
it's the sound of snow
falling
how wonderful that we all get to be here
for someone's final performance
everything is about winning
it's the things we love most but Try Us
they make you feel
[Music]
giving your child his freedom
good
you have been at this for 12 years
[Music]
why are you doing it
because God's children are not for sale
it is the fastest growing International
crime Network that the world has ever
seen
Homeland Security you know we can't go
off rescuing Honduran kids in Colombia
this job tears you to pieces
and this is my one chance to put those
pieces back together
somehow you have failed to bring me one
real world lead
it's over Tim
close up and come back home
you quit your job and you go and rescue
those kids
[Music]
they saw Robo territory no one goes
but if this is your daughter
[Music]
foreign
hear that
[Music]
that's the sound of freedom
and freedom is one of those films that
can legitimately change this world so we
want to ignite a fire in audiences and
open their eyes to the dark reality of
millions of children that need our help
let's make this film a historic event at
the start at the end of child
trafficking theaters across this country
are already selling out pre-order your
tickets today
you can send the message that God's
children are no longer for sale
[Music]
for centuries Our Kind has stayed hidden
on Earth
the darkness has found us again prime
this is about the fate of all living
things
Unicron is coming
[Music]
come on
Becca Oh I thought we were boys
not a human here I'm nobody I ain't even
see nothing I'm not even seeing anything
right now
this is not our war
Optimus we must trust each other to
protect the home we all share
how big can this guy be uh he eats
planets so like way bigger than a planet
in the end
everything you cared for
will be consumed
maybe there's another way to save our
home
you've never faced anything like this
let them come
thank you
[Music]
yo Noah Take the Wheel
yeah baby
Our Lives
are the sum of our choices
[Music]
foreign
this mission of yours
is gonna cost you
dearly
the world is changing
truth is Vanishing war is coming
it's been a long time friend
you've no idea the power I represents
it knows your story and How It Ends
oh
listen to me
the world's coming after you
his fate is written shall we write yours
too if anything happens to them there's
no place
foreign
what's your objective
what's your ultimate objective
your life will always matter more to me
than my own
none of our Lives can matter More Than
This Mission I can't accept that
[Music]
foreign
oh my God
this might be the nicest thing anyone's
ever done for me
[Music]
they don't have love in their culture
they find romantic stuff super exotic
and interesting
they watch you'll go on dates
dinner is one of our most cherished
human rituals do you have to do this
right now Chloe you're not supposed to
talk about the broadcast on the
broadcast
[Music]
hey would you keep that out of my
line of sight why don't you keep your
out of arlana's side you didn't
invent courtship broadcast
[Music]
it has recently become obvious you are
deceiving your viewers what deceiving
the title title of your broadcast is
Adam and Chloe in love and yet you are
not in love
I want you to repay all funds you have
received wait we've already spent
everything we made just to live
and your families will be in debt for
approximately six Generations
do you want me to cut that for you
where is the nearest restaurant
no part of my body can make that noise
well it certainly won't if you don't try
we can get that love back
romantic love is the most poetic of all
human love notes it should never be
faked
unders like any other person I want to
grow up and fall in love and be swept
off my feet
just came here
we've overcome a lot too
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm retiring well in that case what are
we drinking same for the goddaughter God
told me you found something on a train
during the war a dial that could change
the course of history why are you
chasing the thing that drove your father
crazy
no move please get out of here
sorry
[Music]
it's yours get him
Hitler made mistakes and with this I
will correct them all you stole it then
you stole it and then I stole it it's
called capitalism
[Music]
[Applause]
you've taken your chances made your
mistakes
and now a final Triumph
give them hell Indiana Jones a few times
in my life we're seeing things
I'm gonna torture with voodoo
shot nine times
included once by your father
ah sorry
[Music]
well I've been looking for this
all my life
all right
[Music]
I think that we ought to change our
Town's slogan a great place to call home
is confusing I suggest a great place to
refer to is home
we need a crosswalk on Trent Avenue
between Frost and Allegheny and also
oh my oh UFO has crashed my backyard has
taken out my azaleas and destroyed my
bird bath
you talk like that it makes them all
take a less seriously
did you just say
ufoot what is that you remember the
spaceship this is the little man who
came out of it he's got a busy don't
tell anybody
she shouldn't know we gotta trust if
there's nothing else we can do you could
kill her kill me
kill me
you think we can call him Jewels he's
not Jules he's more of a Gary your dad
was in here earlier he said he was
buying apples for an alien like an
illegal alien thank you for the picture
he hands them to me all the time maybe
he's trying to tell you something dad
come on I'm worried what you have said
has not been normal I'm okay how can you
say that when you're buying apples for
an alien
[Music]
the government is searching for a
security satellite that crashed any
moment we waste is a moment they can
discover him you've seen the movies you
know what happens to these guys when
they fall to Earth
[Music]
Jules has come to mean quite a bit to us
it's about Dad buying apples for an
alien
for hanging out together we got along
pretty well we're so thankful for you
[Music]
what the
okay
I want to fly let's do this yeah
you got a force it to come out would you
you're a genius I know like what'd I say
oh did you know what was gonna happen to
my brother when you stuck him with this
world destroying thing
it's called the Scarab
I had no idea it would activate it has
to choose you
so how do we get it to untrust me
[Music]
post acquired who said that distance
tracking three okay
overreacting
benefits
around
eliminated sorry about that
what do you think the government is
going to do when they figure out that
some kid has this military attack
with the power of this
it belongs to me
but I swear
the world is a place to protect I have
an Arsenal at my disposal
whatever you can imagine
I can create yeah that's more like it
low you feel for your family makes you
weak you're wrong for him that's what
makes me strong
oh I forgot how bad it looks
you're the Blue Beetle if I could use
that Arsenal right about now God you
never asked oh yeah
press it down bust it down
I advise me back away
oh my God
hi I love you thank you crashing you
into Mr Wayne no please don't stop
Barry
so you're saying you could travel back
in time
but Bruce I can fix things I can save
people
I can save my mom I could save your
parents
you can also destroy everything
I love you too so how was it this week
how's school Google was good
oh
this is mad trippy dude this is
catastrophic
this world must die
again
it's not Clark my name is
wait he's Batman
you want to get nuts let's get nuts
for an unguarded territory
we try not to die
are you ready ready let's go
[Music]
you have fancy friends
yo who's an Uber oh exact
[Music]
ly
I have been having it the strangest
dreams
Rachel dreams are not reliable
analytical material that's so 20th
century
hi Rachel we're delighted to let you
know that we've had movement on our
waitlist
we got a spot at the womb Center
but I haven't told LV yet why Rachel
Rachel
[Music]
he wants a natural child
but hold on you put us on a waitlist to
have a baby in an egg no it's not an egg
it's it's an egg
women are reluctant to have children
because it's not made convenient we want
them to pursue their careers and dreams
we can't live in the past I want to have
a child with you I still
really yeah
I'm sure you're all very excited parents
are raving about it it is the ultra
solution
my nephew was born at the womb Center
but he doesn't dream I wouldn't worry
about it
[Music]
I can't do it with a pot in here what
are you talking about it can't see us
I feel Alvey is able to bond with a
child but I'm not
maybe I'm just not ready to be a mother
you know no one's a mother just like
that you become one
we are considering having a home birth
I'm sorry it's not possible I won't
raise this child without nature
congratulations it's so exciting is it
I noticed a change in productivity you
do have a baby at the womb center right
why
family Dynamics are about to undergo
true none this changes
how can we make sure our baby's not
bored in utero oh yeah we don't want any
bored babies
[Music]
ETA five minutes to the war zone we must
all right
[Music]
foreign
I'm Brooklyn's one and only Spider-Man
and things are going great oh yeah
you're supposed to be here all right
whatever whatever wow whatever so are
you like a cow or a Dalmatian I am
spot
that's not funny
don't don't do that
miles's grades are pretty good A and AP
Physics that's my little man and a B in
Spanish what okay miles
to you and I think you know it
[Music]
miles
wanna get out of here oh win
so wait a minute there's an elite crew
with all the best spider people in it
who's the new guy danger this is
unbelievable this is the lobby
the whole thing with his idea what's the
guy I gotta do to join this spider team
you can never be part of this don't even
get me started on Doctor Strange and a
little nerd back on Earth 1999.99 come
on go easy on the kid he had a terrible
teacher Peter miles you have a baby
Mouse being Spider-Man is a sacrifice
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saving every world
to send me home I can't do that I can do
both Spider-Man always always what about
Uncle Ben if not for Uncle Ben most of
us wouldn't be here
you can't run forever dude I can't lose
one more friend
no idea what are you doing
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go
[Music]
stop Spider-Man
and then I looked at my uncle and ah let
me guess he died
[Music]
thank you